amum it's good to be here good to be
here Mah and see all these faces and see
all these people in this place in the
heart of Europe in the heart of Europe
the biggest country in the EU
Germany Germany however Germany and its
politicians have been very negative
recently wouldn't you agree with
that in fact I've been doing a ser and
I've been trying to find
out which is the most pro-israel and
anti- Palestine country in
Europe and I've come to realize with
considerable regret that I have to tell
you actually it's the politicians of
Germany and I'm sure you all know
that and a lot of it is to do with the
historical
past it's no secret that these are the
lands of the
Holocaust this is the place where Hitler
commanded for all of these things the
final
solution the racist and
fascist regimes of Hitler it took place
here in fact this is the place where
anti-Semitism Jewish anti-Semitism
reached its
peak and the reason why I make
clear of Jewish
anti-Semitism because for me I don't
accept that the word
anti-Semitism should be only for Jewish
people you see the word
Semitic comes from or it includes Arabic
Aramaic and a range of other
languages the Arabs are also a citic
people and the Palestinians are also a
citic people so I distinguish between
Arab anti-Semitism and Jewish
anti-Semitism and Jewish people do not
have have a monopoly on anti-Semitism
they
cannot by virtue of linguistic
reality however Jewish anti-Semitism in
this country reached its
peak I just come from a museum called
the Terra Museum or something like that
where it was talking about all the
things they used to do and all the
proclamations one of those proclamations
was the nurur laws many would know what
the nurenberg laws are now the nurenberg
laws were a set of discriminatory laws
which rendered the Jewish people below
citizens that's what they it did in fact
it stopped certain marriages from taking
place but the reality of the
situation is
that the German people or at least the
German
populations yes they did Den naify but
their politicians
they have detached themselves from one
Fascism and attached themselves to
another and the fascism that they have
attached themselves to is the Israeli
fascism the Zionist fascism you see
those nurburg laws many of them are
extremely similar to the apartheid laws
of Israel for
example for example a so-called Israeli
Arab citizen cannot
marry cannot marry an Arab from the West
Bank or Gaza and if they do marry them
they have to relinquish their
citizenship this is a very similar law
to the laws that they had in
urur and we're seeing that the
politicians in this country cannot even
condemn this apartheid law what is
worse is that the law of return
in Israel is a law which forbids Arab
Palestinian people from even coming back
to retrieve their houses or even coming
into the borders of their homelands this
is worse than the nurburg laws this is
worse than the nurburg laws because the
nurburg laws did not stop Jewish people
from coming back to Germany this is more
fascistic than urberg
laws
because it's based on ethnicity and
race and so the message that needs to be
portrayed because I
understand I understand that many of us
have become intimidated they have become
intimidated by their labeling they label
us as extremists and terrorists and
anti-semites
and they do all these things to try and
intimidate
us from speaking the truth about what's
happening in Palestine and
Gaza but they are the ones who are
falling into the same
mistake
again Olaf
Schultz who proclaims just like many of
the
politicians that the
reason for a country like Germany to
exist in fact is to help or allow Israel
to exist how
humiliating a country so big so strong
with such manufacturing intent the third
largest GDP in the
world that the only reason for your
existence the only reason that you
exist is to protect the state of Israel
by any means necessary how humiliating
how degrading
so I want
to send a
message to Olaf
Schultz and I want to send a message to
the German
people
[Music]
[Applause]
y I've been told I sound like Hitler
unfortunately I know the secret police
are here and watching and listening
I don't know what they call the secret
police here but I think it's called the
Gestapo as they should be
called well those people need to
understand that we are not
afraid of
them you know in the constitution of
Germany there's clear
provision for you as the Muslim people
to practice your religion and even to
practice it
openly the thing years I've been
speaking to many people including
lawyers in this country and I asked them
because I saw in Berlin when they tried
to thwart and stop and Halt and
inhibit the
protests and it was a fantastic protest
and I think you should give yourselves a
round of applause for
that and many people across the world
saw saw it and they were impressed by it
and we also saw how they were trying to
suppress the rights of the people
Banning Flags Banning garments Banning
different
slogans it's the invisible nurburg laws
that they want to enact on
us that's right it's the invisible new B
laws but constitutionally and
legally they cannot do such a thing and
they shall not do such a thing and we
must continue the pressure because when
this
ceasefire ends and it will end in a few
days we will all be required to act
again we will all be required to be
active again we will all be required to
go on the streets again
we will all be required to go online
again you guys have an
advantage you know the German language I
don't I exhausted everything I know
about German just
then in fact I was walking in the
streets and someone said to me guten
Morgan I said yes I did do good on P
Morgan's show thank you very
much and
[Applause]
understand I realize it means good
morning so I'm starting to catch the
words here and there understand but you
guys can fluently speak it and it is a
difficult language for someone coming
outside the grammar is different the
syntax is different even the
pronunciation is different there's a lot
of going on if you have maybe a semetic
background it will be easier for
you like we're hearing a lot of these uh
zionists on
tvas I don't know where I mean I don't
think the Hebrew has a hat I I have to
look back at it but they don't have a
hat so they
sayas so they they say as well when they
was time to eat the no say give me
the anyway doesn't matter what they say
the point I'm making to you guys is you
have a serious Advantage you can speak
you can understand English you may
understand another language as well as
German you're all polygot here you are
in the 100th percentile in the world of
acknowledging languages and knowing and
acquiring languages which means that you
are very special you are very important
you are very
unique and you're strategically placed
in the right place in the center of
Europe in the biggest country in the EU
by GDP and by
population and you can make a difference
and in fact the politicians here need to
hear it more than any other politicians
almost anywhere in the
world because they are funding the
Israeli
Lobby they are giving them guns and we
know the Germans are fantastic at
producing manufacturing
things and this is dangerous honestly
they're good at making in the cars and
all those kind of
things so imagine putting
that to harm our brothers and sisters in
this is very dangerous so we need to be
extremely Vigilant and cognizant of
these
realities so we are in a very special
place but we as Muslim people we have
special things
also and this is something that nobody
else can buy nobody nobody else can have
and nobody else can acquire number
one we have faith now I want you to
think about something for a second if
all of the armies in the world the
American Army the German Army which now
is basically the American Army I mean
let's be honest how many bases there are
here in Germany there's more bases here
than any any country in the
world and the English army the British
army all these armies the French AR all
them come together
yes now they could do a lot of things to
us they could imprison us they could
torture us they could kill us they could
destroy us however what they can't take
from you objectively and logically
speaking what they can't take from me is
my faith they can't take our Iman it's
logically impossible they cannot take
your faith away from you so this is the
value of Al
IM the value of faith of a
of believing in
muham and then after
having that ingrained imbued embedded
instilled into your heart and into your
mind you also
have or Reliance of
God the Reliance of Allah that you
realize that in control of the whole
world is not the American economy or the
British econ eony or the German economy
or the American Army or the British army
or the Israeli Army but it's Allah he is
the one controlling all of our Affairs
he is
Al and so therefore we do we rely upon
Allah having IM andul Reliance pure
taul on Allah it gives you bravery
because then you are able to take risks
you otherwise would not take because for
other people people death is the
beginning for us death for other people
death is the end for us death is the
beginning which is why we believe that
for each of the 15,000 people that have
been killed men women and children and
we have seen some horrendous images some
excruciating and saddening and
depressing images we have seen those
with the children in the rubble and
we've all seen that
one of the brothers saying to the sister
come out of the rubble and he won't
leave without her the man coming to the
Masjid and bringing bags of his own
children inside the
bags like if anyone has Humanity in
their heart they cannot see these
images and make light of it there's no
way let alone
justify the continual destruction of
such civilians such
children if any was as
Humanity however the good news for us is
that we believe and we hope that each
and every single one of these people are
martys are
sh that they have been transported to
the next
life that they are with Allah alive
being provided
for that these children these women
these non-combatants these defenseless
people are alive they are happy Allah is
telling us they are
happy Allah is giving them something
better and Allah told
us that one of the reasons why this
happens calamities happens
so so he can take some martys from you
so he can give them the prestige
of being at the higher echelons of
J so this is the Solace that we have as
for an atheist an atheist does not
believe in the
Hereafter an atheist does not believe in
heaven or hell when the atheist body
gets destroyed everything gets destroyed
there is no Hereafter imagine that
Subhan Allah imagine us seeing children
women being killed and being in an
atheistic position
where we think to ourselves nothing's
going to happen to nothing's going to
happen that's it it's just a tragedy in
fact it's just a rearrangement of atoms
in fact it's just whizzing atoms moving
around and now they're just re
redistributed imagine having such an
Outlook you see now how Allah has
favored you with Al
Islam you see now the blessing of Islam
you see now what having
a and having pure faith
and believing in the Hereafter how it
makes you not only braver but it gives
you hope and
resilience have you not seen those
people in Gaza showing incredible
resilience which means
patience they have hope even though they
are in the most hopeless
situation is that not an
inspiration it must be it is and
inspiration to all of
us and Allah wants us to be inspired
Allah wants us to think about death and
what better way for all of us to wake up
from our
Slumber than to see death right staring
us right in the face in the images that
we're
seeing Allah doesn't do something
without a reason remember this
everything has a Divine wisdom
a an appropriate
relation there's not a thing that
happens in the universe except that
Allah willed it allowed it and meant for
it a greater
purpose sometimes you can hate something
and it can be good for you and Allah
knows and you don't know and we know
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and the sahabah the
companions that they went through
boycott they went through torture and
they stayed
firm we know that in the meccan period
for
years they were harmed they were
harassed some of them were
killed you know the story of bil and you
know the story of suya and you know the
story of Amar and you know the story of
these
names but look what happened Allah he
put them through this tribulation so
that he can put them on the next level
because they were the people then who
went on to conquer the
world he had to clean up expunge
strengthen their mindsets so that they
can make Iman and the Hereafter a
priority and the only way to do that is
to put them under severe tribulation and
it happened over and over and over again
it happened in the mechan period it
happened in the Battle of khandak which
is very similar to what is happening now
the battle ofab if you read the Quran in
chapter 33 and you read about the Battle
ofab where literally al- Medina was
besieged and they had to dig trenches
around it and they were hungry inside
and they were trying to get out and they
couldn't get out and then all of the
Confederates were trying to kill them
and they had to fight back from within
the Medina very similar to the situation
that we have in Gaza with the
bombardment the aerial bombardment of
the people we have
there and look how Subhan Allah and this
is amazing and
shocking that the prophet sallallahu
alai am when he was so hungry he was so
hungry that his wife AA said in this
battle he had to wrap and and a rock
around his stomach just to trick his
body into thinking there's food
inside this is the depth of hunger
yes and one time he was there with a
rock and he smashed it
once and he said allahar and the people
said why he said a sham has been opened
the lant which by by the way now
includes Palestine just to let you know
the Asam has been open and
conquered and then he said Yemen has
been open and
conquered and he
said one other
place FIS has been opened and conquered
yes so three and these are the biggest
empires of the day Asam was part of the
Roman Empire the Persian Empire was
these were the two biggest ones and he
was telling the people you're going to
get victory when they're in the most
desperate moment can you imagine in the
most desperate moment he's telling them
we going to have Victory when he's
hungry the people can't find food he
said the victory is going to
come then he said it and exactly what he
said
happened and the Muslims were only a few
people there were only a few people
maybe what a few
thousand to to say we're going to take
over the Roman Empire and the Persian
Empire the Roman Empire has been going
on for thousands of years in the Persian
Empire for thousands of years between
them thousands of years to say that
we're going to take over these Empires
as barnab barnabi Rogerson one of the
historians non-muslim historian he said
it's like the esos taking over Russia
and America at the same time the eskimos
the on who live in the the igloo the Ice
House someone living in Iceland saying
I'm going to take over this one I'm
going to take over that one Russia and
America the fact that you have these
hungry people in the desert that are
being attacked and they're saying we're
going to take over this and that now
let's put it in our
context according to Pure research by
the end of the century will be one of
every three people on the Earth Muslims
will be one of every three human beings
on the earth there's 59 out of 196
Muslim majority
countries as it stands there's about 2
billion people who are Muslims on the
face of the
Earth the prophet told us in the end of
days we will reestablish ourselves and
that Victory will come and many of us
despite these predictions and despite
the track record of perfect predictions
of the
Prophet some of us have wh and doubt and
Sheek and
R we shouldn't have any doubt because
this is a promise
that the Muslims will unite once
again and that they will be strong once
again so that this doesn't happen to
us the question is not if the Muslims
are going to be victorious whether the
Palestinians are going to be Victorious
and so on the question is
when and a further question is whether
me and you are going to be a part of
that I'm going to open up inshallah for
questions and
answers